would you go to space if you had a
chance
would you still do it if the spacecraft
was an air balloon i'm talking
a really big one
what kind of training would you need to
complete before you went up there
how high into the atmosphere would you
get
and what are the chances of getting
whisked into space this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you rode a balloon to space
ever tried breathing in a lung full of
helium
helium makes the sound waves that your
vocal cords produce
travels three times faster than normal
and that makes you sound like a pixar
character
we represent helium also makes
air balloons float up in the air
it's kind of a big deal because of how
rare
and non-renewable this gas is
that's why the air balloon that would
take you to space
wouldn't be filled with helium it would
be fueled by
another gas with a similar effect
hydrogen and it would be the experience
of a lifetime
in essence what we do is take a capsule
up
with a balloon big enough to float on
top of the earth's atmosphere
and then float there for a few hours
and then gently float back down
and splash down in the ocean and get
picked up
just lights up like the spacex capsule
does
okay wait i didn't know you could get to
space
so easily but that's the concept that's
being developed by a company called
space perspective and we've got their
founder
and co-ceo taber mccallum on the line
so space perspective is developing
spaceship neptune
which will take eight people and the
pilot
to sort of the essentially the edge of
space about 30 kilometers or 20 miles
up using a huge balloon the size of a
football stadium
i don't know about you but i'm sold if
you've always dreamed of seeing the
north pole
this might be your chance to take a
cruise above it
or maybe you've always wanted to look at
clouds from high above
take a good long look maybe
you'll see the world's number one cloud
business system
hey everyone i'm peter and this is
richard and we're on the set of our what
if discussed podcast because we want to
bring you a message from our friends at
netsuite.com
yeah if you're a business owner it
doesn't matter what type of business
necessarily i mean you could be
it could be flying people to the
stratosphere in a balloon balloon to the
stream
that's a business we're not going to
tell you how to run your business
because we're not business experts this
isn't a business show
but what we can tell you is you might be
making it harder on yourself than it
needs to be
yeah that's right so don't let
quickbooks and spreadsheets slow you
down anymore it's time to upgrade to
netsuite
stop paying for multiple systems that
don't give you the information you need
when you need it
like pete said it's 2021 get rid of the
old spreadsheets get rid of the old
school
outdated software right upgrade to
netsuite by oracle it's the world's
number one cloud business system yeah
netsuite gives you control and
visibility over your financials your
hr your inventory e-commerce and more
it's everything you need all in one
place instantaneously whether you're
doing
a million dollars or hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue
save time and money with netsuite yeah
and it's tried and true it's not sort of
out of the blue there's already 20
000 people on the netsuite cloud so you
won't be alone
yeah it's not brand new it's been around
for a long time let netsuite show you
how they'll benefit your business with a
free product tour at netsuite.com
what if schedule your free product tour
right now at
netsuite.com what if that's netsuite.com
what if all right let's get back to our
balloon adventure
before stepping into this craft you'd
want to know all the ins and outs
and we're about to tell you how this
would play out
three hours before the flight you'd
arrive at the launch site and
get a training session with your
instructor so
what no excruciating workouts prior to
the launch
not even a diet change nothing
there's very few physical requirements
there may be an
age limit for minors um but we haven't
found
a practical upper age limit we had
some questions about an 86 year old
woman a little while ago
and our our doctors said she's good to
go
so if you can do a commercial airline
flight you can do this
phew that's some good news from mr
mccallum
that's a level of preparedness i could
handle
and while you're walking around in
excitement the launch team
would take their positions and perform
the final checks
the launch team would unfold a giant
deflated balloon
on a protective mat i know it would be
hard to resist but
try not to touch the balloon just to see
how it feels
you don't want to accidentally scratch
it
the crew would initiate inflation
they'd be pumping in one ton of hydrogen
gas into the balloon
this would take a while
finally you'd step into the pressurized
cabin of the spaceship neptune
and the 200 meter tall balloon would
lift off
when you fly a rocket to orbit then
you're going
so fast that you essentially keep
missing the earth you're always sort of
flying
around the earth if you go up on a
virgin rocket or a
blue origin rocket you go up and then
sort of parabolically
fall back down and what we do is we go
up and then sort of float there slowly
and then
gently come back down so a big part of
that experience is
actually the slow ascent and slow
descent so when you
you talk to a like a pilot or you're an
astronaut you know that
the getting into orbit part or getting
into the space part is so fast you don't
really have time to
understand sort of mentally grasp what's
going on
but we take two hours to get up there
we're going at 12 miles an hour so this
is like bicycling speed to the edge of
space
you wouldn't be alone on this oversized
hydrogen-filled balloon
you'd share the cabin with a pilot and
seven other passengers
and you'd be riding in luxury the cabin
would feature
huge windows comfortable seats a
bathroom
and of course a bar it could be the
perfect romantic getaway
with a great view
at 19 kilometers an hour some two hours
later
the balloon would take you to the
altitude of 30 kilometers above the
earth's surface
you'd cruise around for the next couple
of hours take in the sights from the
stratosphere
it would look gorgeous up there but
that's not exactly going to space is it
stratospheric balloons like the one
carrying you
aboard the spaceship neptune can only
reach altitudes of
up to 50 kilometers that's only
halfway to the point where technically
space starts
the way buoyancy works is that
the atmospheric pressure on the surface
of the earth
is higher than the atmospheric pressure
a foot above it
which is higher than the atmospheric
pressure a foot above it and so as you
go higher the atmospheric pressure
gets lower if you make a balloon and you
and you make that
volume less dense than
the atmospheric pressure around it that
says so we do that by filling it with
helium or hydrogen essentially what's
happening is
the the atmospheric pressure at the
bottom of the balloon
is pushing it up because it's less than
the atmospheric pressure at the top of
the balloon
but this big balloon could only get so
high before it becomes heavier than
air and its buoyancy wouldn't be enough
to push it up any higher that limit
would be
somewhere around this mark where it's
too high for commercial airplanes but
way too low for rockets and satellites
it might not be outer space yet but
it would be high enough to see the
earth's magnificent curvature and all
its beauty
after a few hours of enjoying the view
you'd start to descend
back to earth your pilot would begin
slowly releasing the hydrogen
after two more hours the crew would
deploy a parachute and
safely splash down into the ocean
shortly after the landing
a ship would pick you up oh and
that would cost you 125 thousand dollars
the market demand looks so huge that i
think we're going to be
operationally limited for all space
companies together
but we are looking at ways to bring that
price down
over time i think you know certainly
getting to half that price
in time is possible and then it's
becoming sort of a lifestyle
change question for a lot of people you
know do i get that new car
that bigger house or do i decide to go
if you were determined to ride a balloon
all the way into space you could bring
jet fuel
hijack the spaceship neptune and use
rockets to launch the balloon from the
stratosphere
all the way up to space
well you wouldn't make it very far into
outer space
it's not that easy to break free of
earth's gravity and
leave the earth's orbit so no danger
that happening but
if your rocket suddenly malfunctioned
you'd be toast
you know there are other ways you could
travel into space without jumping into a
rocket
but that's a story for another
what if